build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people
this is VDP buildin Nintendo made its
presence felt at the LA Auto Show by
having West Coast Customs build a
full-sized Mario Kart they replicated
the exact design to promote the release
of Mario Kart 7 meanwhile Ptolemy's
Ellington uses hubcaps to build
creatures our engine is an artist from
the UK that repurposes old hubcaps into
animals and prefers using BMW and
Mercedes in particular because of their
flexibility the Pantera gap is a pedal
power to person walking machines the
legs are based on a mechanism
popularized by kinetic sculptures of
Thea yachts and of Holland and the feet
are heavy steel cups that can spin in
order to reduce friction Jennifer my
astre creates sculptures out of colored
pencils originally inspired by the form
of the sea urchin
she takes hundreds of pencils cuts them
drills a hole in each section
sharpens them and then sews them
together drawing maybe Manzano makes
digital stained glass art and has a
series of Disney fan art with everyone
from Arielle to the Beast while these
doodles take on a life of their own
for this Tokyo artist his portraits are
composed of thousands of improvised
character doodles as a way to break
creative and whimsical charm to fine art
here are some superheroes splatter
[Music]
finally some floating zoos from Spain's
Rafa zoo birria plane due to the release
of The Legend of Zelda Skyward Sword
here's some tributes to the music of
Zelda first up is the overworld theme on
guitar from CS guitar 89
Britany is a bunch of violent covers of
gaming music that she plays by ear
here's song of storms brawl version
[Music]
Jessica plays the warp songs from the
ocarina of time on her custom painted
ocarina
finally a lost woods dubstep remix from
DJ and fixa
[Music]
submit your own VPS at facebook.com
slash vsauce gaming or as a private
message here on youtube and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]